you work with ice-t on svu i love him um
if you had to fight crime
in real life with chris maloney or ice-t
who do you choose and why
people ask me these questions about the
voice coaches you have to answer because
i answer
okay okay okay first of all i feel like
they're different fighters
how lucky am i that this is this is an
embarrassment of riches because
i know you know chris maloney has my
back and he'd
kill anybody that messed with me and um
um but i also wouldn't mess with ice tea
i'm just going to be real with you
i would not mess with iced tea they are
they they are two of the most loyal
awesome men
and i am so grateful to know them and
they're both i think what's so beautiful
about them
is they're so tough and ice has lived
this
whole other life that i didn't know
anything about and i was actually
scared to meet him because i was like
and then he's so kind and so gentle
and has so much wisdom but he comes to
work
every day with this incredibly beautiful
openness and gratitude oh
he's like every day is a good day that
i'm alive but he is um
he's like a little yoda he really is and
you know chris
is um i just love him so much i love my
cast it's such a
it's such an honor to work all i have to
say they're all pretty
badass kelly kelly giddish is a badass
too
okay well i'm just saying you know what
don't pick one pick them all just form a
squad that's what you should i think i'm
all
i think yep i'm still here just waiting
for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help